But, we've gotten into the habit of
whenever you talk about the Crusades,
even if you're pro-Crusade,
you have to start off by rubbing your
hands and and talking about, "Oh, yeah,
yeah, yeah, but uh you know, you know,
what they did then was really horrible,
and what they did then." Which it is,
but why don't we talk that way about
every other war? We don't. I already
know that atrocities have been
committed, but I remember looking at
World War very quickly, and it showed,
yeah, a lot of Americans were implicated
in mass rape of European women. So, why
don't we talk about World War II,
America's entry, from now on, before we
talk about it, before we say it was good
that Americans went into the war and
helped defeat Hitler, okay? We should
start it off by saying, "Yeah, but, you
know,
those mass rapes and the other
atrocities that were committed." We
don't do that. So, that's all I'm
saying. If you want to do that with the
Crusades and start doing it with
everything, okay? Otherwise, you're a
hypocrite, okay?
And I don't, uh you know, I don't have
any truck with hypocrites, so uh you
want to be balanced and objective, then
you take that standard and apply it, and
you're going to find out it applies to
every single conflict in in more
dramatic ways.
But, for what one reason or the other,
when it comes to the Crusades, we have
to find and nitpick and find everything
they did, and but now by saying nitpick,
I'm not saying that what they did wasn't
wrong. I am categorically rejecting and
saying it's bad, okay? But, I'm saying
in the context of warfare, historically,
and what goes wrong and awry, and all
the atrocities are committed by the good
guys, yeah, and that's that happens all
the time. So, the real question is, why
do we always have to talk about the
Crusades that way, but not other wars?
All right? As you know, I like context,
I like balance. Uh if you want to talk
about the bad things the Crusaders did,
which I readily admit to, then you
better start talking about all the bad
things. And but you don't even know
about the bad things they did, do you?
Isn't that interesting? You do know
about the Crusaders, cuz that's the
first thing you're taught. Because, of
course, the whole that's the whole
point, to demonize the Crusades.
But, you don't know about all the other
bad things that your heroes were engaged
in, do you? Bring back the
Bring back the
and the righteous